[Musik]
eine wunderschöne nacht meine lieben
freunde erwartet uns hier in unserer
kleinen sitz mainfeld und wir
arschloch wir meine lieben freunde haben
ja in der letzten episode ja versucht
hier vorne fährt heute freilich würde
jemand irgendwie der mitmachen will
aber bereitet der kripo da hinten die
spinne
meine freunde die auf einmal in der
letzten episode haben wir versucht hier
vorne phantome zu beschwören ich habe
mich dazu auch in den kommentaren
befragt hat irgendwer tipps von euch an
mich dabei allerdings vergessen dass ich
die kommentare ja gar nicht lesen kann
weil ich gerade videos vor produziere
deswegen sehe ich auch aus wie ich
aussehe ziemlich fertig deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht ich versuche einfach
noch eine weitere nacht wir sind in den
statistiken zwar schon
gehört
wir sind in der statistik zwar schon
seit mehr als einer stunde wacht gesagt
das allerdings dass ich mir denke es
wird ja nur daran liegen können dass sie
noch länger wach sein muss weil die
phantome kommen wenn ein spieler
wirklich lange genug nicht im bett lagen
deswegen habe ich mir ein paar andere
sachen für die heutige wieder überlegt
und während ich diese sachen mache werde
ich auch nicht schlafen gehen woher
kommen wir direkt zum ersten punkt und
zwar möchte ich mal wieder zum wasser
dorf und ein bisschen traden mit unserem
einen villa dort von dem ja die ender
perlen bekomme denn ich habe mich mal
ein bisschen informiert über das ende
und wir benötigen auf jeden fall noch
eine menge ender perlen mehr weil der
ender drache uns ja hoch schleudert mit
seiner attacke und wenn wir dann von der
mep runter
[Musik]
an alle die das ende in minecraft nicht
kennen das ist quasi eine insel im
nichts und da kann es sein dass der
inder drache uns runter schleudern
[Musik]
da kann es sein dass senna brach und
runter schleuderte und wir der und
dementsprechend nach außen nichts
ausfallen und sterben deswegen werde ich
meine smaragde mitnehmen und wir werden
uns direkt zu wasser dort bewegen hier
ist nach perfekte gange spinne
ich weiß wirklich nicht wo die alles
meine lieben freunde wir werden uns
jetzt ist
das kannst du dir halt wirklich nicht
mehr ausdenken gefühlt will die ganze
map irgendwie mir nur schaden zufügen
das einzige was ich möchte ist mein
krams sie zu ende kriegen die sache
jetzt allerdings meine lieben freunde
das wird hat es etwas geht hinter mir
habe
[Musik]
ja
könnt euch dorf dach
und leute
triebwerkshersteller hier
es ist doch noch ein vielfaches bond
[Musik]
und der ist weg
ich frag mich wirklich gar nichts mehr
meine lieben freunde das einzige was ich
machen möchte ist mein
kleines schwarzes 443 chillig bleibt
einfach da und heute freiwillig bruder
noch ein vierter da rechts acom wir
meine lieben freunde fahren zum wüsten
dort wir sehen auch schon hinten der
mond geht unter das heißt wir sehen
vielleicht einen wunderschönen
sonnenaufgang hier vorne allerdings
daneben freut euch ja gerade schon
gesagt es ist immer noch nachts die
ganzen leute meiner map wollen mir
unfassbar viel schaden zufügen und darum
soll es auch so ein bisschen gehen in
der heutigen episode minecraft mit luca
denn
man mag es kaum glauben allerdings habe
ich tatsächlich mal wieder einen sponsor
am start und zwar ist clarke der
versicherungsmanager und da ist es
überhaupt kein problem das ich hier in
minecraft schaden bekomme wo der king
der überleitung nie wieder oder das wenn
ich in real life halt schaden bekomme
denn über klar kann man richtig geile
versicherungsschutz finden und lag es
ein komplett kostenloser
versicherungsmanager der euch bei der
suche nach einer passenden versicherung
hilft indem er über 160
versicherungsunternehmen vergleicht und
diejenigen mit dem besten
preis-leistungs-verhältnis herauspickt
und euch in der app anzeigt mit klar
könnt ihr eure versicherungen digital
über die app managen und sieht zudem
eine komplette übersicht und hat
außerdem auch volle kontrolle wie ich
über mein boot hier
warten sie mal ab in den sonnenuntergang
reiten ihr könnt zudem bei clark auch
noch all eure bestehenden versicherungen
eintragen so dass sie immer genau sehen
könnt wo ihr versichert seid und wie ihr
versichert sei über den bedarf check von
klar könnt ihr zudem prüfen ob ihr nach
wie vor gut versichert seit oder an der
ein oder anderen stelle eure
versicherung optimieren könnte und wenn
ihr euch damit selber nicht so richtig
auskennt hat clark auch eine menge
experten die euch im individual- fall
dann weiterhelfen können clark ist nicht
nur komplett kostenlos nein ihr könnt
auch noch einen 45 euro amazon gutschein
bekommen indem ihr drei bestehende
versicherungen in die app eintrag mit
dem kot laser
sind ja alles eingeblendet gerade da
unten ihr müsst also nicht nur eine neue
versicherung abschließen sondern könnt
euch einfach über den ersten link in der
infobox
die hat kostenlos runterladen und mit
dem kot laser drei bestehende
versicherungen einfach einfügen und dann
habt ihr direkt die chance auf diesen 50
auch amazon gutschein hey
[Musik]
natürlich wo ist denn eigentlich dieser
dieb mit dem wie gehandelt haben den
willen haben müssen jetzt auf jeden fall
ganz fix finden allerdings auch mal ein
riesiges tagen schon verklagt dafür dass
mich heute finanziell unterstützen wir
diese erfolge
jetzt müssen wir den idioten hier finden
ich habe keine ahnung ob wir hier
irgendein haus rein gelaufen ist also
hier ist auf jeden fall niemand
dann habe ich hier noch nie in die
häuser geguckt also ich weiß nicht ob
ich gerade ein bisschen dummen aber ich
hab doch die safe schon mal das ganze
dorf abgesucht ob hier irgendwo
irgendwelche items waren oder habe ich
das haus dann einfach vergessen oder ich
kann es sein dass die villa der
eventuell auch sachen irgendwie näher
eingehen
das war ich nicht hier vorne war auf
jeden fall nichts mehr drin glaube ich
wir waren nur noch die weizenkörner was
ist hier auch jetzt ein bisschen wasser
drin da vorne war definitiv nichts mehr
weil hier habe ich auch einfach alles
abgebaut was hier stattgefunden hat und
hier in den häusern weiß ich gar nicht
ob ich da schon geguckt habe aber ihr
müsst ihr dann auch irgendwo aha der
geistliche
warum hat er sich ganz im bilde angehört
[Applaus]
als kann ich nicht mehr sprechen
so ein idiot alter nimmt ihr keinen
einzigen smaragd werden für irgendwelche
ender perlen was soll das jetzt bin ich
völlig umsonst hin gefangen auf bewohner
führen den warenbestand bis zu zwei mal
am tag auf
[Musik]
ich habe auch kein bock mehr auf dich
ich habe jetzt halt keine ahnung wie wir
hier die zeit totschlagen können ich
könnte hier vorne nochmal diese teile
abbauen weil hier bekommt man aus jedem
strohballen neuen weizen aber es kann
ich mir dann immer brote machen das
heißt einen strohballen bedeutet quasi
drei brote zum essen ich kann mich jetzt
alles absuchen aber hier ist ja nichts
bleibt oder welche wirklich noch nicht
drin hier ist nichts ich gehe ich mal
wieder runter ich habe mal hier vorne
gucken hier für alles das war auch mein
ziel von mir das ganze dorf wieder
aufzubauen weil die ja auch alle im
wasser herum stellen die kommen ja auch
nicht hoch aber das ist mittlerweile
auch egal wie jetzt auch nichts drin da
ist nun
das ist ein das ist ein polierter
steinbock ich dachte getrennte das wären
eisen block der darstellen würde schau
doch mal ganz kurz die vornherein hier
war auch nichts drin aber gut wenn er
den ganzen waren wir schon zweimal am
tag auffüllt stand ja dann glaube ich
erst mal hier vorne ist auf jeden fall
nichts mehr gewesen habe ich noch nicht
ganz in sachen
abgeblasen der luft herum ich weiß noch
gar nicht mehr in welche richtung hatten
wir dann hier schon sachen erkundet da
vorne steht noch ein schwein wir waren
glaube ich noch nie da oben auf dem berg
dorf da können wir einfach mal aus jux
und dollerei hinfahren ich weiß nicht wo
mein botox habe ich hier da können wir
einfach mal schauen wer sich da vorne
befindet dann ist es halt ein bisschen
der entdeckungs folge die sache ist aber
generell meine lieben freunde die
heutige episode wird nicht so lange hier
sieht es mir glaub ich schon an ich bin
fotos fertig in die haben mich die
letzten tage sehr mitgenommen ich habe
irgendwie jetzt wieder lokal talk am
leben aber ich krieg irgendwie voll
wenig schlaf ich habe ganz viel in
meinem kopf drin aber die andere seite
will ich dieses minecraft bringt nicht
schleifen lassen ich will das alles
umsetzen ich habe ja auch total bock
darauf allerdings
müsste ich die heute gab die so noch mal
ein bisschen kürzer machen die letzte
war auch schon ein bisschen länger
deswegen entschuldige bitte ich weiß
nicht wie lange die sonne wird ob sie
zehn minuten wird oder oder fünfzehn
oder keine ahnung was allerdings
sprinten wir jetzt mal diesen berg hier
hoch ich war hier auf jeden fall noch
nie oben wir kraxeln hier auf jeden fall
weiter hoch und haben da oben den
höchsten punkt erreicht auf dem wir
glaube ich je in diesem minecraft weg
dann hochgeklettert sind ich weiß jetzt
auch gar nicht ob ich genügend ja doch
das soll ich glaube ich ihnen kriegen
mich da hoch zu bauen ich weiß noch gar
nicht was das gerade bringen soll
allerdings einfach mal um zu gucken was
da oben so abgeht meine lieben freunde
wir sind top of the world
noch mal hier aus ja ich das mal so dass
er hinten
ist schon crazy wie weiter ist ja auch
runter geht sieht man das dorf von hier
es schneit
jetzt sehe ich ja gar nichts mehr
[Musik]
neun leute ich bin luca
will offenbar wird
es dunkel
wird ein bisschen oh
mein gott
[Musik]
oder
so viel glück kannst du mich ich erkläre
ich ganz gucken was passiert es freunde
weil der tastatur hat manchmal so einen
fehler und das
im regen jetzt
ach so es regnet schon die ganze zeit
aber im schnee und regen als stehe
dargestellt also ich war gerade dort
irgendwo ganz oben um eine tastatur hat
manchmal den fehler dass sie einfach
eben die taste einfach drückt und dann
läuft es in die richtung da muss ich die
katze noch mal drücken dass er das
aufhört und er hat gerade da oben
gedrückt sodass nach vorne gelaufen habe
ich bin ich hier drauf gefallen
[Musik]
ach du heilige grüne neune
who okay es ist auf jeden fall nacht ist
jetzt blöd das ist gerade regnet weil
ich es halt leider nicht überspringen
kann der regen nervt halt extrem in der
aufnahme finde ich uns für mich auch im
schnitt ist immer so ein blöder ton
allerdings sieht ja schon dass es dunkel
das heißt es sollten gleich auch
irgendwo monsters brauche ich muss auf
jeden fall die fackel in der hand
behalten damit ihr überhaupt irgendwas
sollten wir euch auf jeden fall monster
spawnen und dementsprechend komme jetzt
hier schnee aber hier regnet
es sollten wir euch auf jeden fall
irgendwelche monster sporteln und zudem
dann dementsprechend vielleicht auch
endlich mal die phantome also wir laufen
jetzt auf jeden fall erstmal wieder
zurück was haben wir nach vorne das sind
nur an die sieht oder keine ahnung was
wir sind schon auch immer so weit oben
okay das ist ja wirklich geisteskrank
wie es hier hoch geht ich weiß nicht
warum die phantome noch immer nicht wie
es bei uns sind ich kann es mir wirklich
nicht erklären vielleicht sparen sie bei
stufe normal nicht allerdings hier ist
das wasser
die ab ins brötchen rein fackeln anzag
ich weiß nicht ob die phantome
vielleicht nicht bei normaler stufe
spawn wir hatten auch ehrlich gesagt
schon genug action für heute weil real
talk dieser sprung gerade von da oben
runter
altenheim herzinfarkt bekomme ich hab
schon wieder alle 40 level flöten gehen
sehen wir können jetzt einmal ganz kurz
schauen ob der wille da hinten sich
unsere ender perrin situation angenommen
hat guck mal die habe ich ordentlich
stress da muss ich mal ganz kurz die
dazwischen reifen
grip
extrudierten kripo
jetzt geht es aber richtig abgehalten
becker
wir mal gerade im krieg eisenrohr ich
weiß eigentlich kennen uns nicht so
richtig aber ich halte ihn jetzt einfach
mal so doch noch die an es geht noch
einmal zum anderen eisen golem davor
muss ich erst mal ganz kurz die spinne
töten ich weiß nicht warum die phantome
nicht kommen ich kann es wirklich nicht
sagen ich es einfach nicht ich sehe
allerdings dass wir vorne die reisenden
auf jeden fall eine ordentliche hand
voll zu tun hat
pauli
es geht hier ab
was geht hier ab
ich kann aber nicht schlafen
[Musik]
ich kann nicht schlafen
ich will ja die phantome kriegen damit
ich diesen krank machen kann von daher
war eine ganz kurze tipps wie ich die
ganze nacht war sie abgewartet habe
es ist tag
meine lieben freunde und es ist noch
immer kein verdammtes kantone zwecks
hier
und leute 26
ich kann diese kritik nicht mehr sehen
ich hab mein herz eingeblendet
das war der gleiche ich habe ich kann
mir das hd2 wächst hier
ich habe euch meine teil bleibt
eingeblendet wie ich die ganze nacht da
oben stand komplett schlaflos
mittlerweile schon fünf oder sechs nicht
ich bin mit langen leute 2 6 4
ich bin mittlerweile schon fünf oder
sechs nächte schlaflos im wikipedia
beitrag steht dass man drei nächte durch
halten mussten das stimmte nicht das hat
bei mir nicht geklappt ich weiß nicht
warum keine ding spawnen warum keine
phantome spawnen ich weiß nicht warum
das nicht funktioniert allerdings muss
ich sein glaube ich im am ende so
hinkriegen dass ich das ohne den trank
des sanften falsch mache wie bereits
gesagt falls sie doch noch irgend einen
tipp habe dann schreibt sind die
kommentare beziehungsweise wenn ich das
nächste video aufnehmen ist das andere
video auch schon online das heißt dann
kann ich mir das auch noch mal angucken
was sie mir da geschrieben habe die
sache ist allerdings dass ich jetzt
meine lieben freunde an der stelle die
heutige minecraft mit dem auch beenden
werde es war eine sehr regnerische
episode allerdings habe ich ja
tatsächlich diesen geisteskranken sprung
nach vorne überlegt ich bin fertig und
ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen meine
lieben freunde wenn es das getan hat
dann das gern einen daumen hoch unter
dem wir da unten ein kanal und liegt auf
die glocke wenn ihr neuer episoden
minecraft luca nicht verpassen wollt wir
sehen uns irgendwann die nächsten tage
wieder und ich freue mich jetzt so auf
mein bett einschlafe
[Musik]